hello my name is rich Hyndman and
welcome to this week in Android
development on Monday februari the 10th
2014 last week Paul cough gave us an
overview of the google cast sdk while
Kevin Nilsson gave us the highlights on
the SDK for iOS crispy went over cast
receivers and Google cast for Chrome and
yes that is his name Nazmul and special
guest Richard Fulcher of the Android
design team explained user research
Nazmul is special guest crazy has won
every single week Todd had another play
games for iOS and coming this week
Fred's mystery dev bite might actually
launch I wonder what one thing Android
developers are hoping will come really
really soon also this week Catherine
quant makes her debut explaining the
Google API client in Google Play
services my contribution to the team
this week has to solemnly promise never
to play flat flat flapping games ever
again and with that that's all for this
week in Android development I'm rich
Hyndman and my head is an animal and
once there was an animal it had a son
that mowed the lawn